[Música]
el chaleco antibalas y el casco que la
identificaban como periodista no fueron
suficientes para evitar la muerte de la
palestino-estadounidense
gering abu el corresponsal del medio
qatarí al yazira un suceso que ha
conmocionado al mundo y que al yazira y
testigos atribuyen a los soldados
israelíes
es un asesinato flagrante que viola las
leyes y normas internacionales las
fuerzas de ocupación israelíes
asesinaron a sangre fría a nuestra
corresponsal en palestina el gobierno
israelí sostuvo que la muerte
posiblemente se dio por fuego palestino
pero los testigos aseguran que en ese
momento no había combatientes palestinos
al peón en toni morrison y existe una
posibilidad viable de que la periodista
haya sido alcanzada por fuego de los
palestinos armados pero para llegar a la
verdad debemos realizar una
investigación real que los mets y
acusaron a la autoridad palestina por
rechazar una investigación conjunta
déjenme preguntar desde cuando el
criminal tiene derecho a formar parte en
la investigación de la muerte de su
víctima la muerte de abu a que le ha
hecho sonar las alarmas entre la
comunidad internacional con los
sindicatos y ongs exigiendo seguridad
para los periodistas y distintos
gobiernos pidiendo una investigación
transparente
pedimos inmediatamente una investigación
rápida e independiente para que los
autores de este terrible crimen sean
llevados ante la justicia
no es la primera vez que un periodista
palestino muere en el conflicto que esta
vez ha terminado con la vida de una
profesional con más de 20 años de
experiencia puede que no sea fácil para
mí cambiar la realidad de la situación
sobre el terreno pero al menos he podido
contribuir ayudando a que esas voces
lleguen al mundo soy heidi na wai